this is delicious Wow I'm so glad we're
doing this together
Sam this is gonna be hard to be I'm in
San Francisco and it's a beautiful day
here I'm gonna meet up with my friend
Alison she's a Bay Area native and she's
gonna show you how to eat and it just
felt like the local what's the leader
Allison hey good to see you yeah dude
welcome to San Francisco are you ready
for a whole day of eating yeah I haven't
been here in years I'm so ready to see
what you have in store I wanted to bring
you here talk to you a little bit
excited
you ready yeah my name is Christa chase
I'm the chef here at Tartine
manufacturing we're in the Mission
District San Francisco we have beautiful
breads as you can see right here in the
literal sense the word Tartine is a
open-faced sandwich so we'll start with
the strawberry Tartine we get to start
with a beautiful country bread we do a
slice of that toasted with a little
house-made ricotta the strawberries are
from dirty girl firms we like to support
local farms especially a female farm -
so you just toss them with a little bit
of sugar cut it on top of the ricotta
finish it with some tarragon and vanilla
gastrique then the coddled egg we cook
the colored eggs in the heath ceramic
bowls we cooked it just through so the
egg is still a little bit runny we top
it with some trout roe
salt pepper olive oil horseradish then
we do some toasted country bread finish
that with Zatara which is a
middle-eastern seasoning that has sesame
thyme sumac we love it'd be kind of like
douse the bread in it I think it's
pretty special this is the strawberry
Tartine what they're known for
and then these are the couple days
they're beautiful
let's dig in I feel like we should go
savory first right yeah coddled egg I'm
just gonna different write it dip it
right in there this looks so silky
smooth this is delicious oh oh it's like
a Middle Eastern spice blend
it's got runny yolk and then there's
trout roe on top which I just kind of
burst in your mouth I come here for this
it's like my favorite breakfast I'm
searching obviously known for their
tartines but this is too beautiful to
eat and here we are
wow it smells like a strawberry
shortcake I just like the strawberry
candy you got the ricotta which is
really smooth and creamy I mean this is
wonderful this is a really popular spot
it's like people come here so this is
just a first stop we have so much and
this is gonna be hard to do table you
cheese are great there
we're in Alma square The Painted Ladies
are over there I feel like we need to do
the full house in turnover right now
it's a big tourist spot people are
loving the nineties nostalgia let's go
to Brenda is one of my local favorite
spots just around the corner yeah let's
go that sounds great yeah
[Music]
i'm brenda buen viaje chef/owner of
Brenda's French soul food here in San
Francisco
Brenda's French soul food is my
restaurant that I dreamed about for
decades born and raised in New Orleans I
wanted to bring southern food to San
Francisco the most favorite dishes here
are beignets we stuffed them with
different flavors we have a plain
beignet Ghirardelli chocolate beignet
granny smith apple and honey beignet and
a spicy crawfish and cheddar beignet
those are all really popular so here we
are at Brenda's great local spot there's
like a line out the door yeah Oh
when a plague we should start with
crawfish that's it savory it's a fluffy
spiced beignet with this like creamy
crawfish in the center I love the heat
on top I've never had a savory beignet
before and you know let's try the apple
and I feel like you'll like it I mean
the dough outside it's not overly sweet
the apples have just the right amount of
like cinnamon and spice I mean you
literally have a loaf lightly I worked
on a fried chicken recipe for a better
part of a year it's become a really big
fan favorite first thing we do is we
bring in local fresh chicken every day
we make a brine made of buttermilk
crystal hot sauce salt and pepper garlic
cayenne onions and we actually hold the
chicken in that police 24 hours and then
the next day we take it out roll it
around in our seasoned flour and fry
those when the chicken comes out and
it's served with french fries our famous
cream biscuit I really wanted a nice
spicy fried chicken that I grew
eating also that had enough flavor so
that when customers sat down the eat the
chicken
they weren't reaching for this condiment
that condiment I ordered us with fried
chicken and it is he best I promise you
Wow the chicken looks incredible
huh that outside is crispy and rat flu
it's perfect and the inside is so juicy
this is exactly how Fried Chicken to
taste it has the faintest amount of
spice I don't even need hot tops I'm
gonna find the biscuits ooh I'm gonna
tear the jam all of these jams are made
in-house right like you can tell that so
much time and effort has gone into every
single element of the dish we open a
year or so after Katrina happen and
there are a lot of displaced people who
just showed up being able to just like
bring that to people and then also teach
the bay area what really good it's
southern food to taste like it's been
amazing
thank you so much for bringing me her I
would definitely come back I'm glad you
like this we're in Chinatown this is
very iconic to San Francisco
so we've got some egg tarts here yeah
it's like a buttery flaky mm-hmm rusty
was like a custard it tastes kind of
like a flan yeah dude it's like a mix of
ugh oh my god it's so good I love try to
town I've been going here for like years
ever since I was a kid I think this is
like an iconic place to bring someone it
would be trying to amaze stable love it
[Music]
flour and water
that's pasta in the city I've always
wanted to eat here and I've never had
chance to so glad I'm going with you hey
Brian Paul now the Executive Chef of
flour and water here in the Mission
District
our pasta program is pretty extensive we
feature many different styles trying to
capture different towns but also trying
to represent Northern California almost
as if it was a region of Italy will be
those pastas look like to start the
tasting menu which want to feature stone
fruit little agretti on a pistachio
crema with ricotta salata one of our
farms currently supplying us with all
this beautiful stone fruit French plum
yellow peach white doughnut peach pluot
which is a hybrid fruit to dress the
stone fruit Tosca olive topping on the
base of the dish is just a small amount
of a pistachio crema
this is agretti a house-made ricotta
she's gonna add another layer of
savoriness to the fruit well there how
beautiful it's too beautiful it's stone
fruit season and it comes together so
beautifully it's so good it hurts I feel
like this is how we're starting the meal
it's perfect yeah currently we're
featuring the first pasta which is a
doppio essentially a side by side
ravioli it's picked up with some pickled
squash blossoms additional shaved
truffle and toasted seeds for texture
it's for you to get into the pasta I've
never had a ravioli with two different
fillings like so how does that work
yeah the pasta itself like that is the
star that we look so good and nuts and
seeds on top of pasta it really adds is
like crunchy element and the sauce I
can't even describe it it's not heavy at
all it's a beautiful looking
I have to love eating ready I love you
the next one will be the farfalle our
pork pulpit eating seasoned with chili
flake fennel pollen these are purple
dragon beans red gypsy peperonata fresh
parsley only garnish for this pastas a
little bit of an aged parmesan reggiano
Wow
this looks like my dream pasta yeah this
family style yeah really nice to eat
this way
it's spiced you can taste the pepper in
it okay if this was a Limi ball I had to
eat for the rest of my life I'd be
thrilled actually it doesn't feel happy
to even I think that's just like the
balance of flavors right you can taste
some acidity you have the saltiness with
chili some heat so it's all these things
working together feel a lot more than
totally the one thing we can't take off
the menu is the chocolate budino
rich chocolate pudding covered in a
bunch of Maldon sea salt and then a
caramel espresso whipped cream and I
think if we took this one off the
dessert menu our regulars would revolt
finish you off a little sweet treat to
round out the tasting menu this is a
dark chocolate budino
so pretty this is incredible I think
that's because it doesn't taste too
sweet exactly
savor the moment know everyone's had
chocolate pudding yeah and virginity is
like a fancy version of that it's like
more rich and more creamy more silky
this is the chocolate I want to eat they
change the menu all the time but this is
a house favorite it's always on the
common thread throughout every dish that
we've had the salad the pasta the
dessert is that everything is so
well-balanced I had so many awesome
experiences to choose from in San
Francisco and now I get to choose how to
pay for them with peut Planet from
American Express this is the perfect way
to end this day thanks for visiting me
[Music]